well tell us about OMG now OMG has been
very successful
um Got my swag here uh OMG O'Keefe Media
Group so that when they type in OMG it
can't be censored because it's a
commonly used acronym on social media
that's brilliant
um and it and what this is a very
ambitious Vision
um which is to effectively create
Uber for journalism so instead of just
everyone being on my payroll I want to
equip everyone to go do what I do so
everyone oh so I get you know hundreds
of messages a day please investigate the
school board in Utah I had a lot of
Canadians message me today that was
interesting
um and what we want to do is equip them
give them cameras and to go have them go
do this and open source my knowledge so
everything I've learned about what I do
I'm producing a series of master classes
on ethics law technology and I'm
teaching people how to do this because I
think it does require some skills it
requires being being trained and
educated and I'm going to open source
that I'm going to put it behind a
paywall O'Keefe mediagroup.com you can
subscribe it's 20 a month and you can
get access to this information we have a
database of like 1100 people and we're
deploying them
um and we're doing as I speak they're in
the field recording follow-ups on Pfizer
the FDA the government the Deep State
the administrative State the three
letter agencies so school boards
teachers media companies we want to help
everyone but when people say hey James
can you please go do this story now I'm
saying no you go do that story
it's on you I'll give you a camera I'll
ship a 500 camera I'll teach you but you
gotta figure it out because I can't do
it all myself it's not sustainable one
of our biggest stories is is now getting
Congress to act this is the um act blue
uh donations that were being funneled
into individuals with like 10 000
donations on their name and things like
that that's crazy how did you find out
about that that was found out by a
citizen journalist in Wisconsin election
watch Peter is his name and he just went
on the web FC website he's like well
that's odd this one guy this modest guy
in Annapolis has got made like 10 000
donations and I just went to knock on
his door
and and they said well I'd like to
donate that many times but I didn't yeah
so so it's leading to congressional
action now yeah right on well I mean
imagine if the rest of the media
actually did that and followed those
leads instead of publishing articles on
why Star Trek was racist
but that's the thing writing writing an
article about Star Trek being racist
clicks super easy money yep and and
what's happening is this kind of of
media is becoming dominant and then it
results in
surface level understanding of the world
hyperpolarization and people focusing on
things that are substantially less
important you get YouTube channels where
they're like we're gonna make our 160th
video about Dave Rubin and I'm like but
Dave rubin's a guy on YouTube like you
could talk about the president uh you
know uh I think we talked about David
Pacman and I unfairly criticize him for
talking about Trump so much and now I
realize no that's actually fine like if
you're going to talk about the president
a thousand times I totally get it you're
right you should if you're going to talk
about AOC if you're going to talk about
people in positions of power and
authority heads of Industry that I
understand if you're going to claim that
a YouTuber who ranks at like number one
thousand no that's just that's just
vapid e drama but it's easy to make it
Riles people up at the lowest common
denominator it makes money and it's very
difficult to do the research people want
to hear their opinion being uttered by
somebody else but that doesn't actually
change anything thing I mean why don't
journalists do this my theory is they
don't do it because if you actually
point a camcorder or a hidden camera in
any direction in a bureau or a
government office it'll contradict what
you see on television yeah like reality
contradicts narrative and the other
thing is I I think I think I've always
said that we hold a mirror up to people
and they don't like what it is that they
see they they hate the person who holds
the mirror up to them so I mean going
back to the citizen journalist thing we
had we had people that are so humbled
that we reached out to them as Texas
people I was speaking to there's a group
of people exposing something local in
Texas and she was shocked that OMG that
James O'Keefe would would send her a
camera like well you're going after like
Pfizer and the Pentagon and the Deep
state so why would you talk to us it's
like well you've got to start local got
to go to your local school bar meeting
right but Tim you were downstairs with
me and I was on the Twitter spaces and
and someone said well I don't know where
to start and I said have you gone to
your school board meeting yet she said
no I didn't know I could don't doesn't I
don't have to have a kitten school is
like no you're a taxpayer go to your
school board meeting yeah put on these
little cameras and talk to people in the
hallway and see what you come up with so
we're starting there do you hire them or
do you uh have them as contractors or do
you just send them stuff to get started
we have a form on our website
o'keefeedgroup.com you click on the link
and there's a citizen journalist request
form and we just ship them a camera
provided they're not
um
insane or stupid
insane or stupid uh we'll send you a
camera and uh you know you'll have to
maybe perhaps sign a waiver
um and then we'll pay you we had we had
a young woman in Minnesota record her uh
official in college
saying shh don't we transgender person
will be in your room as your roommate
but we won't tell you that they're
transgender saying this to to her and
she recorded it wow and and we paid her
a thousand bucks for the footage for the
footage okay well I think that's a very
important Mission because you're putting
a lot of emphasis on what's happening at
the local level and it's good to focus
on National politics obviously everyone
in this room does that but for
individual people in any given Community
to be involved with their school board
and then also be able to see like
undercover journalism on what's going on
at their school board I think is
incredibly valuable
I think so too it's so necessary dude
all I want is because I'm a big fan of
Barrett for the people I know at Veritas
I love them the people I met the people
I mean obviously you you're like my
brother I mean I don't know I know each
other Band of Brothers yes you did Henry
the simple few four parts too yeah yes
um and I want you guys succeed O'Keefe
why do you think that do you think that
there's a way for these organizations to
both just keep firing on all cylinders
absolutely
I wish them well I hope they keep I hope
they do what they do I want everyone to
do this
I think everyone should do this I don't
think people should stop people from
doing this
I don't think we should I don't I don't
think it's uh I think it's an uh against
the First Amendment to stop journalism
and stop trying to use the federal
courts to stop journalists I've been
sued so many times in my life I had the
teachers union in Michigan file an
injunction against me in 2017 Randy
Weingarten actually filed a restraining
order against me because I published a
document showing they paid off fifty
thousand dollars to someone who's
accused of raping a child wow and they
issued an injunction in federal court
against I mean I defeated that
injunction they they were demanded well
they initially got it it was it was a
temporary restraining order in federal
court in Michigan this is still this is
still going on five years later I
haven't settled the cake now I'm not in
charge there anymore
but you see what's at stake here oh so
your ass like okay Veritas I saw yours
well no but I do I didn't I didn't want
that to be the case no I know yeah but
whoever is in charge has to now deal
with
this this dichotomy of okay I gotta
raise ridiculous amounts of money to
fight on principle or I can settle and
give up so in Michigan this was this was
a document where it was paid off 50
Grand we got the guy in hidden camera
saying he knows what he did we published
a story we get sued no one comes to our
defense
hundreds of thousands of dollars I'm
deposed I go through depositions in um
with these with these lawyers for the
teachers unions and and that's its own
form of torture
um but uh but that's the price you pay
so for this company OMG for O'Keefe
Media Group are you is it like you're
obviously private right now do you have
any ambition to take it public
that's that's such a uh I'm taking it
one one week one month at a time
probably not I mean I'm I'm I've trust
issues right now yeah with ownership
um I 100 own it I haven't taken on any
debt
um
no equity I we had a very successful
launch we have thousands of paid
subscribers which is pretty good for an
organic launch yeah
um and we'll take it from there we do
have a 501c3 and C4 that I'm not on the
board of I posted that link to my
Twitter Liberty guard to C4 they're
gonna help pay for legal defense to pay
for lawyers and and private citizen
which is a 51c3 liberty guard and
private citizen if you want to donate
and get a tax deduction to help pay our
legal costs you can donate to to those
organizations are you with them do you
work for them no they're they're boards
just are their mission is to is to
defend citizens who are being under
attack and being silenced uh like in
this case so they'll take donations to
support uh paying the attorneys so it's
just insane how much of this is lawyers
and just legal fees people have no
people have no
people have no idea I didn't I mean well
I knew that for what you were doing you
ended up getting sued a number of times
so I figured that that was a problem for
you I didn't realize how much that added
up well it was also like the legal Court
the system's expenses case in 2019 jury
verdict in North Carolina you probably
none of you knew this it was like a jury
verdict woman sues me for defamation for
quoting I quoted we quoted Scott Vogel
and Scott fovel is saying what he said
and they sued me I don't know why
they're suing me they should sue Scott
foible and it gets all the way I had to
fight it for like two years it goes all
the way right before the verdict the
jury is coming out of the box and the
federal judge gavels the case and goes
and I'm paraphrasing a federal judge
article 3 judge says can someone please
tell me why we're here wow and and the
lawyers the plaintiff's lawyers these
are these are like the Hillary Clinton
sort of make money group right I don't
know how this old woman could afford
like five lawyers that's another story I
had two one of them was blind the and
that was intentional because the jury
sympathized with him as much as they did
to her justice is Blind Justice is blind
and and the judge goes if you is
directed at this is a transcript
directed at the Lord if you sued Mike
Wallace I realized Mike Wallace is dead
60 minutes but if you sued Mike Wallace
for what you're suing James O'Keefe for
everyone would laugh at you
and you should have seen the look on
these lawyers faces
they were like whoa we didn't expect
that so sometimes you have to fight it
all the way to join legal fees it took
last year we won back 15 grand
because in the United States it's capped
yeah right you don't you don't we got
administrative fees back oh so that
covered what wonderful faxes and like
copy scans and things like that I think
people need to understand this
if someone sends you a demand letter or
a threat or an intent to file and you go
to your lawyer and say okay how should
we respond to this they'll say well
we'll draft a response 15 grand bang
that's why everyone loves lawyers so
much yep thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time